you are an amazing uh guy you really are
and you're really interesting and you're
um
i i think
there's such a dichotomy between your
public persona yeah you know i i watch
ridiculousness because i love the the
funny clips and you come off like a
skateboard dude who was uh you know like
one of the jackass guys and then i
talked to you and there's so much
it's very surprising i don't know if
that's uh
don't didn't you find that like when you
showed up i didn't expect yeah who you
are you also wrote a book you're writing
a book yeah yeah is the book out no
it'll take me a couple years to do it
right it's a philosophy that i want to
stand the test of time like think and
grow rich or the science of getting rich
or the richest man in babylon these sort
of
deeper philosophies that are fundamental
that um you could read over and over for
hundreds of years and still be
applicable i did also hear from my
husband who i think knows chanel
um west coast that you are just like the
most giving person in the world and that
you really take care of not just your
family but all your friends and people
that you are really close with yeah yep
was that a question it wasn't a question
i'm just saying stupid it was a
statement it was a statement that i
heard look whoever's closest me is about
to get 100 g's
but look hey like but you gave her a
career yeah yeah but it's the you know
at the end of the day it's like it's the
greatest thing
you want to be able i want to help as
many people as i can in a direct and
impactful way you know what i mean like
as opposed to as opposed to like being
you know like doing charity work if you
will like you know i
you know i just like impacting lives and
then the lives that are closest to me i
just don't want you to ever have to
worry about money because like you know
is money the answer is money the answer
but but it's it's not the
money is never the answer but at the end
of the day if money
kills your mindshare and does not allow
you to reflect and evolve and grow
because you're constantly thinking or
stressing about it it's going to
deteriorate your health the quality of
your life and ultimately your existence
and so the people closest to me
if i can
productive towards making them happy i'd
rather that happen doesn't necessarily
mean they're not going to do that and
not continue to fight other issues
within themselves but if i can
alleviate that one which is fundamental
to living
uh to those closest to me that's that's
why i stay committed to that when i
google rob uh dudex net worth
it says 400 million
is it are you that happy
look
let me tell you something about about
net worth and money right
like if you
it's it's still the balance sheet of
your existence right so if you spend 100
grand a year and you have 20 million in
the bank
you're gonna be happy as a fiddle you
know what i mean if you have 10 million
in the bank and you spend a million
dollars a year you're going to be
stressing right and then then for me it
goes even further
to then the type of assets that your
money lives in and you're worth is based
in and because it really boils down to
um how much you spend how much the way
that you live and the is connected to
your identity and then how much you have
supports that right it's like whenever
that becomes you don't ever want to be
trapped by needing to do more you want
to do more as a in in an effort to add
to your legacy your purpose your
passions versus like needing uh to be
able to maintain your lifestyle so
anybody if they
uh
find success and don't keep those
balance they're gonna get into trouble
you know
because then you're doing stuff you
don't want to do for money versus like
your money working for the lifestyle
that you've created you know wow so
what's your view for your kids and
teaching them about money so you never
want them to have to worry about money
and so you're going to support them
provide for them but isn't it
important that they learn then how to
like manage their money and still
understand
finances
i'm teaching i mean i'm i already teach
we talk about everything he like as it
relates to building a company he's five
years old he's like i got a perfect idea
for a company
he's like it's a pizza with honey and
i'm like son that is genius that's how
you have to think son and i'm like it's
it's a big market share but it's a
unique sort of uh a look at the space
you could do your own thing what would
you call it he's like delish honey and
i'm like man that's actually a good name
and i went and bought delish honey.com
it was available and like i'm like man
like and so to me
i will teach every single aspect of
money because it's like you can you
still have to make a ton of decisions
with money like you know for me i like
cash flowing
real estate right i don't like owning
public equities i like investing in
companies that i've started i own i
totally understand i like keeping a ton
of cash i keep five years of cash of my
lifestyle expenses and then i have
almost all of my money in a
non-correlated cash flowing real estate
right right because of all the the tax
benefits and everything to boo but i
my lifestyle is never compromised in
that system but that was the system i
created right and so i want them whether
whatever they
um do growing up you have to look at
your life through the lens of whatever
you earn as post-tax right and then your
expenses and then what are your goals
you got to set a goal with money if you
don't have a goal with money and what
you're hoping to achieve with it that is
sort of your own personal financial
freedom then you just kind of
um spend your life making a little bit
more saving some money here without
without having a definitive pathway and
end game
i think is just what most people
most people don't ever take the time to
design they don't and i always say to
people like they'll go you know people
don't know what they can afford you know
i want to buy a house what do you think
i can afford and i'm always saying it's
like fourth grade math yeah you know it
really is and people think there's more
to it than there actually is and there
isn't yeah and and i me i i don't think
our school system our education system
it doesn't teach what is important what
a mortgage is what lending you just as
soon as you learn what a percentage is
you know you should
they don't uh equate that to what we're
going to use it in life for yeah you
know even math and calculus i don't know
how i use that whereas i can
but almost nothing in school teaches you
and prepares you for how to live a
fulfilling high quality life you know
because at the end of the day you have
to learn
you know sort of understanding yourself
and the self-awareness to be able to
even design the life that you want to
eventually lead because it's like
anything else like if you don't design
what happiness is for you your and
create a pathway to get there then
you're just gonna try all these little
things hoping one of them is the answer
when the answer is actually within you
to design and then create the path to go
and do it
and no none of that thinking in in and
especially as it relates to financial
um sort of like education and what your
career is for and how all these things
will lead to
uh giving you a balanced happier life i
just think nothing in school teaches any
of that stuff robby you gotta open up
your own church of productivity
no you're an amazing aspirational
inspirational
good human being who um i accidentally
got to know i've been a fan of yours for
years a fan of your television show for
years and now uh you know i think you're
an amazing human being and i can't thank
you enough for being here and uh letting
us talk to you and kind of inspi i i
would imagine that listeners are going
to listen to this over and over and over
again this is an episode that um you
need to listen to and you need to listen
to again and you need to learn from and
and that's what i you know i'm very
proud that you were on here and you kind
of
expounded on our you know a podcast
because i'm going to tell people and and
every day people go i've got investments
or i want to do things i'll go listen to
the rob dry dick episode
dear dear dick dear dick
again but you're amazing
[Music]